que vous croyez que vous pouvez avoir un
jour un contrat en chantant comme ça
quelqu'un passera
bien sûr
dans la rue on trouve on trouve du
boulot ça arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme tous les jours derrière ces murs
rigides on oublie parfois qu'il existe
un ciel qu'il existe des arbres cette
réalité celle des rues de la foule et du
bruit et celle qui aujourd'hui
s'imposent à nous
et si un soir les rêves s'étendait sur
les villes si nos yeux traversaient les
murs et si la musique prenait possession
des rues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous vivez de la musique
non non je fais d'autres boulot vous
jouez à quel moment tous les soirs
ça dépend j'essaie de jouer le plus
possible
ça dépend des rencontres j'ai rencontré
un copain brésilien qui
et vous êtes retrouvé pour jouer de la
musique ensemble dans la rue
[Musique]
de quelle heure à quelle heure
joue le matin l'après-midi le soir
quelle est l'accueil que l'on fait dans
la rue en général
on s'est rare qui est des réactions
violentes en général c'est ça c'est bien
accueilli ou parfois une musique qui est
pas très agressive
[Musique]
ce que vous pensez que les gens sont
attentifs
1 sur 10 à peu près c'est déjà pas mal
quand même
ouais
en chantant comme ça quelqu'un passera
et je chante pas bien sûr
dans la rue on trouve du boulot ça
arrive et combien d'années vous jouez
ici
on s'est fait trois jours
[Musique]
imaginons qu'un matin la ville se
réveille mais pas comme d'habitude
[Musique]
ce matin-là les rêves vont envahi Paris
la musique s'impose partout
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il
les musiciens se rejoignent
leur musique peu à peu libère nos sens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il était au bord de la route
fatigué assis sur le salut
hola ah ça y est par le doute
mon prince qu'il attend le plus
un bon à rien c'est pas bon à grand
chose
jouez toujours dans la rue
quelques fois mais surtout dans les
restaurants dans les salles ça fait 10
ans 15 ans avant de que je devienne un
troubadour à temps complet je travaille
dans l'assurance
[Musique]
c'est à dire ce que j'aimerais c'est que
mes chansons puissent se faire entendre
devant une audience plus large
et non disons que je tiens le choc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces musiciens ils existaient déjà
aujourd'hui il se voudrait magicien pour
faire rouler les murs arrêter les temps
illusoirs et répandre leur folie jusqu'à
la liberté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a beaucoup de problèmes avec la
police quoi j'ai pas mal d'amandes que
je ne peux pas payer d'ailleurs
pourquoi il faut une licence spéciale
pour jouer dans le métro
il n'y a pas de musiciens il y a des
mendiants qui se déguisent avec un
instrument de musique ou autre ça plaît
beaucoup à certaines heures oui je pense
que je vais rapporte quelque chose oui
mais en revanche il m'apprend pas grand
chose
grand maximum 40 45
pour faire 10 ans
quoi faut faire un livre ou avoir très
peu d'argent faire des trucs très très
commercial genre Claude François tout ça
c'est vraiment horrible c'est la
prostitution en quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un jour la symphonie universelle
reprendra tous ses droits et l'invisible
deviendra l'essentiel
[Musique]
S